Bayonetta the angel hunting Umbra which
is back for her third installment in the
much beloved Platinum Games title with
the planned release date of October 28
2022 fast approaching here is everything
you need to know about Bayonetta 3.
[Music]
the original Bayonetta was created and
directed by Hideki kamiya the same man
behind Devil May Cry and the Advent of
the arcadey combo heavy 3D action game
style so after creating a 2d game in a
similar style via Beautiful Joe kamiya
created what would become another
beloved combo heavy action game
Bayonetta Bayonetta took with Devil May
Cry started and added a stylistic new
protagonist in its titular character as
well as standout gigantic boss fights
her clothing is her hair which she also
uses for magic and to summon demons and
there's overt sexual overtones
throughout while kamiya created and
directed Bayonetta Bayonetta 2 would be
directed by yusuke Hashimoto with
supervision from kamiya and now
Bayonetta 3 is seeing yet another
director with yusuke Miata taking
control of the project and kamiya
serving as an executive director miata's
past involved designing on various anime
titles and since was credited as a game
designer on the wonderful 101 and astral
chain and level designer on Metal Gear
Solid 5 ground zeros he was also the
lead designer on the now canceled skill
bound and a tweet from scalebound's
former lead producer JP kellems one of
Bayonetta 3's new mechanics controlling
summons is similar to a mechanic from
scale bound JP kellems also mentioned
that he felt yusuke Miata was a super
talented designer so while yusuke Miata
may not be a super recognizable name it
sounds like he has plenty of experience
under his belt as well as a lot of
respect from his peers
speaking on those summons let's talk
about the gameplay like the previous
installments to Bayonetta Bayonetta 3 is
a combo heavy action title what that
means is a heavy focus of the game is on
the combat itself with a score running
throughout while it isn't necessary to
beat any level typically you'll want to
rack up the highest score possible
through Flawless and varied combos while
avoiding damage in order to earn a
higher ranking at the end of each level
this system allows players of a lower
skill to beat a level but also gives a
high skill cap for dedicated players who
want to become the best you'll be able
to play as multiple characters in
Bayonetta 3 who control differently so
let's start with Bayonetta herself
Bayonetta controls mostly like she did
in previous games with each button
corresponding to a different type of
attack like punching kicking or shooting
with her gun boots and doing different
button combinations to pull off combos
dodging is also an important mechanic
not only in avoiding damage but by
pulling off the Dodge at the right time
you'll be able to activate which time or
brief slowdown in time where Bayonetta
can attack enemies as their attack speed
slows through a crawl Bayonetta can also
summon infernal demons to aider in
battle these demons are Ultra powerful
but also quickly drain bayonetta's magic
meter while also leaving her more
vulnerable to attacks meaning you'll
have to strategically bounce back and
forth between using them doing so you
can add to your combo while these
infernal demons were in previous games
they now work as demon slaves allowing
the player to have more direct control
over them Bayonetta also now has a demon
masquerade ability allowing her to fuse
with the summon demon and Grant her
additional abilities these infernal
demons are attached to bayoneta's
various weapons meaning that switching
weapons on the Fly allow allows you to
not only increase bayonet as possible
moveset and combos but also summon more
infernal demons to help with battle some
of these infernal demon abilities go
beyond the battlefield their unique
abilities can also help Bayonetta
explore and find secret Areas when not
in battle with one such example being
Bayonetta masquerading as a spider and
shooting her web to essentially triple
jump and then climb up a wall players
will also be able to control a brand new
character in Viola Viola is a witch in
training who utilizes a sword in Magic
darts while she seems to overall control
mostly like Bayonetta their abilities
differ such as activating which time in
a different way whereas Bayonetta
activates which time while pulling off a
Dodge at the right time Viola activates
which time by countering an enemy's
attack at the correct timing whereas
Bayonetta has multiple demons she can
summon the only one we know of so far
for viola is a giant Cheshire Cat which
is attached to her blade Cheshire Also
may work slightly different and as an
ally rather than a demon slave while
Cheshire is a Channel Viola can't use
her which time and fights with her fists
Bayonetta 3 also includes various
accessibility modes while it includes
the general casual standard and expert
difficulties Bayonetta 3 is also
included The Immortal marionette
accessory players can equip this makes a
so Bayonetta automatically performs
various combos by just tapping one
button the mode is meant to help novice
players but as a caveat does penalize
the player's score on standard mode and
higher Bayonetta 3 also introduces a new
naive Angel mode which conceals some of
the nudity in the game as well as some
of the more graphic enemies
from Bayonetta 3's the witching hour
trailer it seems that Viola is
specifically training under bayonetta's
tutorship the threat this time around
comes from the man-made monkey lie who
serve as this game's major antagonist
and seemed to work for an evil entity
known as the singularity in the Witching
Hour trailer we see Bayonetta seems to
be defeated at some point in time with
Viola needing to take charge however
this could be some sort of fake out
especially as there's different versions
of Bayonetta running around from
different universes so who knows if it's
our Bayonetta Viola's Bayonetta or just
some sort of other fake out entirely
unfortunately I can't talk about
Bayonetta 3 without briefly touching on
the controversy so here we go fans of
the prior Bayonetta games may have
noticed the voice actress for Bayonetta
sounded different as it turns out Helena
Taylor the voice actress of the previous
games was no longer voicing Bayonetta
and had been replaced by seasoned voice
actress Jennifer Hale at the time
according to Miata this was due to
various overlapping circumstances on
October 16th Helena Taylor released a
series of videos on Twitter that blew up
and went viral in these she alleged that
she was only offered four thousand
dollars to voice the entire game it
didn't reflect the living wage for voice
actors and she called for fans of
Bayonetta to boycott Bayonetta 3. Hideki
kamiya responded to this on Twitter
saying sad and deplorable about the
attitude of untruth that's what all I
can tell now by the way beware of my
rules fans were irked in particular by
him saying beware of my rules although
these rules to my understanding are that
he'll block anyone who doesn't message
him in Japanese
on October 18 2022 Bloomberg reported
that Platinum Games had wanted to rehire
Helena Taylor and offered her between
three thousand to four thousand dollars
per four hour recording session not
total with a total of what would come to
around at least fifteen thousand dollars
for roughly 20 hours of work this goes
well above current union rates which
according to sag-aftra are between 900
and 960 dollars per four hour recording
session according to Bloomberg sources
which includes documentation Helena
Taylor then asked for a six-figure sum
plus residuals Platinum turned this down
took on a new actress and then offered
Helena a cameo role for the fee of one
session this story was also corroborated
by video game Chronicle in response
Helena Taylor initially called the
report an absolute lie and a complete
joke then on October 24th she revised
her statement saying she was initially
offered ten thousand dollars negotiated
up for fifteen thousand dollars and
declined deciding that wasn't enough
money still she claims four thousand
dollar dollars per session for five
sessions is a total fabrication on the
side of Bloomberg the report was done by
Jason schreier who's a seasoned games
reporter and has broken plenty of
difficult stories often aimed against
the game industry for mistreatment of
employees and he's regarded as a highly
reputable Source I will say for my part
A game is made by a giant team of
dedicated people who probably had
nothing to do with this situation all
putting years of work into this product
so you can decide what's right for you
based on what we know
Bayonetta 3 releases exclusively to the
Nintendo switch on October 28 2022 and
that wraps up everything you need to
know about Bayonetta 3. I do wonder if
you haven't played a Bayonetta game are
you thinking about hopping on here as
your first one let us know and I'll see
you guys next time